>> Larry: I KNOW YOU JUST DID
A DOCUMENTARY CALLED "HOT GIRLS
WANTED."
CAN YOU TELL US A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT IT?
>> "HOT GIRLS WANTED" IS A
DOCUMENTARY ABOUT 18-YEAR-OLD
GIRLS WHO GO TO MIAMI TO TRY
AMATEUR PORN, PORN STARS.
>> Larry: PORN STARS OR
AMATEUR PORN?
>> AMATEUR PORN IS A FORM OF
PORN.
I MEAN, IT SOUNDS LIKE --
>> WHAT IS THIS PORN THING
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT?
>> LET'S DO IT AFTER THE SHOW.
>> I WILL SHOW YOU ALL KINDS OF
AMATEUR PORN.
>> HEY, NOW.
>> NOT THAT I'M IN.
I KNOW HOW TO FIND IT.
>> Larry: LET ME SHOW YOU WHAT
IT IS LARRY!
I FEEL LIKE THE WHOLE CULTURE
HAS KIND OF BEEN PORNIFIED IF
THAT'S A WORD.
PORN SEEMS LIKE NO BIG DEAL
ANYMORE, RIGHT?
>> SEX IS NO BIG DEAL ANYMORE.
>> Larry: WHAT DO YOU MEAN SEX
NO BIG DEAL?
ARE YOU IN THE CLUB FIGHT AGO.
>> I MEAN, REALLY, THIS SOCIETY,
SEX IS NOT LIKE WHAT IT USED TO
BE. IT USED TO BE TABU,
NOBODYTALKED ABOUT SEX.
NO MY SON WENT ON MY COMPUTER
AND
I SAW 18 PORN SITES ON MY
COMPUTER WHEN HE LEFT
>> Larry: THAT WEREN'T THERE
BEFORE.
>> THAT WEREN'T THERE BEFORE.
AND I APPRECIATE HIS TASTES
>> Larry: SO NOW THERE ARE,
LIKE, 66 PORN SITES.
>> EXACTLY.
I DON'T MIND.
IT'S DIFFERENT AND NEW AND FREE.
>> Larry: IS THIS A NET GOOD
OR A NET BAD FOR SOCIETY?
PORN, DO YOU THINK IT HURTS OUR
RELATIONSHIP, ALL THIS PORN OR
DO YOU THINK ULTIMATELY IT
HELPS?
>> I WOULDN'T EVEN SAY GOOD OR
BAD.
I MEAN, IT'S INEVITABLE, RIGHT
IN WE'VE BEEN LEADING TO THIS
DIRECTION FAIR LONG TIME.
>> Larry: THAT'S WHERE THE
WORLD HAS BEEN GOING.
>> IT IS.
THINK ABOUT IT.
SEXUAL LIBERATION, WE HAVE BEEN
COMING TO THIS-- I CAN'T SAY
THAT.
HEADING TOWARDS IT-- HEADING
TOWARDS THIS POINT FAIR LONG
TIME.
I THINK THE QUESTION IS HOW CAN
WE PROTECT OURSELVESES FROM IT
AFFECTING OUR RELATIONSHIPS.
BECAUSE I HAD HEARD FROM PEOPLE
THAT IT AFFECTS, LIKE, PERSONAL
INTIMATE RELATIONSHIPS.
THEY DON'T WANT THEIR KIDS
WATCHING IT BECAUSE THEY SORT OF
TREAT IT AS EDUCATION WHEN IT'S
NOT.
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
ENTERTAINMENT.
YOU SHOULDN'T LEARN ABOUT SEX
FROM PORN.
>> I DISAGREE.
>> YOU DO?
( APPLAUSE )
>> Larry:
>> I BELIEVE PORN IS A NET GOOD.
THERE ARE THINGS I HAVE TRIED
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE TRIED--
>> BUT YOU'RE AN ADULT.
>> I'M SAYING AS LONG AS
EVERYBODY IS AN ADULT.
IN AMERICA, 18 IS AN ADULT.
YOU CAN VOTE.
YOU CAN JOIN THE THE MILITARY.
THAT'S AN ADULT.
>> Larry: IS 18 TOO YOUNG FOR
GIRLS TO BE IN PORN?
IS THAT PART OF WHAT THE THE
MOVIE--
>> THE MOVIE DOES TALK ABOUT HOW
WHEN YOU'RE 18 THE CHOICES YOU
MAKE ARE DIFFERENT THAN THE
CHOICES YOU MAKE WHEN YOU'RE 35.
AND THE THINGS THAT HAPPEN TO
THESE GIRLS ARE NOT ANYTHING
THEY ANTICIPATED.
THEY GO FOR FAME AND GLAMOUR AND
THEY ARE MET WITH A VERY
DIFFERENT REALITY.
>> I THINK 18 IS FAR TOO YOUNG.
I THINK THAT--
>> Larry: TO GO INTO PORN.
>> TO GO INTO PORN.
>> Larry: YOU CAN GO INTO THE
ARMY AT 18.
>> THAT IS TRUE.
>> Larry: AND WATCH ALL THE
PORN YOU WANT.
( LAUGHTER ).
>> THAT'S TOO YOUNG FOR THEM,
TOO.
LIKE OUR BRAINS ARE THE LAST
THING TO MATURE, AND WE MAKE A
LOT OF STUPID DECISIONS AT 18.
I KNOW I DID.
SO I THINK IT'S WAY TOO YOUNG.
I THINK IT'S TOO YOUNG.
HOWEVER, I DO HAVE TO BACK UP
WHEN YOU SAID THAT PORN ISN'T
EDUCATIONAL.
I'VE LEARNED A LOT FROM PORN.
>> Larry: THIS SIDE OF THE
TABLE LEARNED A LOT FROM PORN.
>> YOU GUYS --
>> Larry: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE WATCHING WHEN YOU WATCH
PORN.
OKAY, I THINK WE LEARNED PORN IS
GOOD AND PORN IS BAD.